la France a cette avantage d'être
champion champion d'Europe dans les
déficits jumeaux les déficits du mot
c'est à la fois le déficit budgétaire et
le déficit commercial et là pour que la
gemilité soit complète le déficit
budgétaire et le déficit commercial sont
équivalents 160 milliards à peu près
pour chacun je vous félicite pour cet
effort
simplement
plusieurs économistes commencent à
s'inquiéter de la faire et ils ont
raison
par exemple nous dit entre 2019 et 2022
la France a perdu des parts de marché et
c'est un dégradé son sol extérieur dans
quasiment tous les secteurs industriels
entre 2019 et 2022 la France perd du
terrain par rapport aux autres grands
pays de la zone euro entre 2019 et 2022
la perte des parts de marché touche
quasiment tous les secteurs des biens à
l'exportation compte tenu de cette
constat que comptez-vous faire pour
changer de direction